this is how you make the fluffiest
omelette ever start by separating five
eggs and we're only gonna need three egg
yolks for the other two egg yolks save
them for something else whisk them until
they're smooth and pale in color then
whisk the egg whites until they triple
in size and we're looking for medium
Peaks here add in our egg yolk carefully
fold our egg yolks into our egg whites
until fully Incorporated let's cook our
egg evenly spread this out cover with
the lid and let it cook until the bottom
has set let's lift up the side and drop
in some butter cook for another five
minutes season with some garlic salt
some pepper and there it is the
fluffiest omelette ever
[Music]
now floppiest omelette I've ever had
it's like an egg cloud in my mouth